NICOLA MARZARI:
Welcome, everyone.
Lecture 8-- hopefully this
will be a somehow simpler class
to follow than last class.
That was sort of
heavily theoretical.
What we are going to
do today is really,
after two or three slides of
recap of what we have seen
in the past lecture,
we'll go into really sort
of practical application of
density functional theory.
We'll first discuss how
you set up calculations.
That is, what are
the parameters,
and what are the
objects that you
manipulate when
you do an electron
[INAUDIBLE] calculation?
And then we start seeing
a number of examples
to give you the feeling
for the properties
that we can calculate
using density function
theory for the accuracy
and for the pitfalls
you need to be careful with.
And in the next
class on Thursday,
we'll finish up with
more case studies.
So let me actually
spend three slides
to recap what we have
seen in the last lecture.
Starting somehow from
this, that, I would say,
is the most fundamental one.
And it's really rewriting
quantum mechanics.
So this is really the
Schrodinger equation
from the '60s, density
functional theory.
And this is what it says--
that we don't really
need to solve a many-body
differential equation to find
that the ground state charge
density, and the ground state
energy, and the ground state
properties for a system.
But we can actually solve it
using a variational principle
on the charge density,
and the functional
that has to be minimized
is written here.
That is, for any given
charged density and prime,
we have, at least in principle,
a well defined functional,
and we need to change to vary
the charge density and prime.
And the minimum value that
is functional will take
is actually the
ground state energy.
Somehow, sort of the
weakness of all of this
is that everything is
well defined in principle,
but it doesn't work in practice.
To remind you what were the
sort of conceptual steps, what
Hohenberg and Kohn proved
from their first theorem
is that, given any charge
density and prime--
more or less any charge
density and prime,
an external potential v
prime is well defined,
for which that charge density
is going to be the ground state
charge density.
This was sort of the inverse
part of the first Hohenberg
and Kohn theorem.
And then, at least in
principle, the solution
to the Schrodinger equation
corresponding to v prime
is well defined.
And we call that c prime.
And so one can construct a
functional f that is just
the expectation value
of p-- psi prime
over the many-body
kinetic energy
operator plus the many-body
electron-electron interaction.
And so this here is the well
defined, at least in theory,
density functional
term that is here.
And the other term
is just the integral
of the external potential
times the charge density.
So everything is well
defined in principle,
and so in this, it's a
perfect reformulation
of the Schrodinger equation.
The real problem
is that we don't
have an exact representation
of this universal density
functional.
And so what Walter Kohn
and Lu Sham did was they
tried to figure out
an approximation
to get a universal functional.
And so in the total
energy functional,
these were-- this was their
choice for the approximation.
That is what they
said-- is, well,
let's try to figure out what
are the most relevant physical
terms in this functional, and
then we'll sort of leave--
sweep under the rug all
the many-body complexity
of this problem.
And we'll call data an
exchange correlation function.
It is really where the fine
detail of your solutions are.
And so what they said, in
this universal functional,
we can extract terms like the
Hartree electrostatic energy,
written here, that is a
very simple and well defined
functional of the
charge density.
The sort of second term
was the tricky one,
because they wanted
to figure out
what was a significant
contribution
to the overall quantum
kinetic energy.
And as we have seen,
there isn't really
a good way to extract kinetic
energy that's basically
a second derivative of the
wave function-- of curvature
of the wave function
from a charged density.
The sort of most remarkable
case is that of a plane wave.
A plane wave of any wavelength
gives you a constant charge
density, but gives you a very
different second derivative,
very different kinetic energy.
And so what Kohn and Sham did--
they introduced a related system
of non-interacting electrons
that, for a given charge density
n, they would have the same--
sorry, they would have
the same ground state
energy of our original problem.
But because these are
non-interacting electrons,
one can define exactly what
is the quantum kinetic energy
of this set of
non-interacting electrons.
So if you want, this
is just a definition,
but it turns out to be a
definition of the second piece
that makes our third piece
here very, very small.
So by extracting, selecting
the green and the red term,
we were left with an
exchange correlational term
that, if you want, still
contain all the complexity
of this problem that it's
well defined in principle,
but we don't know how to solve.
But for this, then, they
applied that the same idea
of Thomas and Fermi.
That is, they said,
well, maybe we
could try to approximate
this exchange correlation
term with a local
density approximation.
That is, we try to construct
this energy term by integrating
an infinitesimal volume
by infinitesimal volume,
and each infinitesimal
volume will contribute
to this many-body problem
and exchange correlation
energy density that is the
exchange correlation energy
density of the interacting
homogeneous electron
gas at that density.
So when, in 1980,
Ceperley and Alder
first did very complex
calculation-- quantum Monte
Carlo calculation
of the interacting,
but homogeneous electron gas
as a function of the density,
this functional, at
least in principle,
was, for the first
time, parameterized
over a whole set of density.
Often we call that the
Perdew-Zunger parameterization,
and so we had finally
a working expression.
Once we have a
working expression,
then the problem of
finding the ground state
becomes our electronic
structure computational problem.
That is how to find the
minimum of this functional.
Note the very significant
difference with respect
to Hartree-Fock.
In Hartree-Fock, we had
a variational principle,
and that led us
to our expression
for the energy for the
Hartree-Fock equation,
in which there was a well
defined exchange term.
It was written somehow
complicated-- complex, but well
defined.
But because it was
basically coming
from a variational principle,
we had the possibility
of making Hartree-Fock
better and better
by extending our class
of search function
from Slater determinant
to more flexible classes.
We could just take,
say, combination
of Slater determinant.
So Hartree-Fock, in principle,
can be made better and better
in a systematic way.
And the computational cost that
you will pay is horrendous,
but it gives you an avenue.
Density functional theory
doesn't give you an avenue.
It sort of monolithically states
that there is going to be,
in principle, a well defined
universal functional,
and in the Kohn and Sham
sort of the composition that
is going to be in particular
one single given exchange
correlation functional,
but it doesn't give us
any sort of systematic
route to find
better and better functional.
And that's why for many
years there wasn't really
much applied work using
density functional theory.
Sort of in the
early '70s, people
started studying
very simple system,
like the surface of a
metal sort of represented
as a step in a free
electron gas solution.
And then it's only sort of the
beginning of the '80s, when
we had the
parameterization of LDA
from the calculation
of Ceperely and Alder,
that people could sort of put
together an overall working
algorithm.
And I've shown you in the
last class sort of the phase
diagram of silicon,
the first time
that we see somehow that this
theory is going to give us
a very accurate practical result
and will be able to give us
the lattice parameters,
the bulk models of silicon,
just by plotting the energy
as a function of the lattice
parameter, or it will give
us even the phase transition
to high pressure
phases of silicon.
What I had written in the
previous slide was the total
energy in this density
functional paradigm,
and we had, as a
computational goal now--
and you see how
we address this--
the task of minimizing
that total energy.
And there are two main
routes that we can take.
Once the exchange
correlation potential
is written in an
explicit form, this
is a well defined, even
if nonlinear, functional
of this independent
single particle
orbitals-- the Kohn
and Sham orbitals
of which the charge
density is just
the sum of the square moduli.
And so we can look at this as a
nonlinear minimization problem.
We need to find the orbitals
that minimize this expression,
or as it often happens, we
can write the associated
Euler-Lagrange equation.
We have a variational
principle so we
can take the functional--
the functional
differential of that,
and that gives us
a set of differential equation
that is what we call the Kohn
and Sham equation.
And again, they are
written here-- sort
of not very different.
If you look at it, from
the Hartree-Fock equations,
there are really the same terms.
There is a quantum
kinetic energy.
And now these are single
particle orbitals.
There is a Hartree term.
There is an external
potential term,
and the only difference
is in the way
the exchange or exchange
correlation term is calculated.
In Hartree-Fock, it was
an explicit integral
of the orbital.
In density functional
theory, it's
going to be some kind of complex
function of the charge density.
And we are going
to try and find out
what are the eigenstates of this
Hamiltonian, of which the most
important part that
you need to remember
is that this Hamiltonian is
what we call self-consistent.
That is, it's an operator
that actually depends
on its own solution, because
you see, what we have is
that the charge density
is given by the sum
of the square moduli.
And the charge density goes into
the expression of the Hartree
operator, and goes into the
expression of the exchange
correlation operator.
So the Hamiltonian, acting on
this single particle orbitals,
depend on the charge density.
And the charge
density is a function
of the orbital themselves.
And so the problem has
become slightly different
from your usual problem.
The Schrodinger
equation gives you
an operator for which you
need to find the eigenvectors.
Here, you have an operator for
which you find eigenvectors,
but then these
eigenvectors give you
a charge density that,
put back in here,
gives you a different operator.
And so exactly like
in Hartree-Fock,
you have found your
ground state solution
only once you have
become self-consistent.
You have Hamiltonian
whose eigenstates give you
a charge density that gives you
the same Hamiltonian you had
calculated the eigenstates for.
And so all the
computational approaches
to solve the density
functional problem,
as those that solve the
Hartree-Fock problem
are iterative approaches.
We can't just find a
solution to an Hamiltonian,
but we really need to make
that problem self-consistent.
So this is where we
concluded in last class.
And so now we'll actually
go into practical feature
of density function theory.
So starting from reminding
you that all the quality
of your calculation
depend ultimately
on the quality of
your functional.
And for many years, the only
functional that was used
was really the local density
approximation functional.
In the late '80s and
early '90s, people
started to develop what are
called generalized gradient
approximation.
That is, they constructed
functionals of the charge
density that didn't only depend
on the charge density itself,
but also on its gradient.
Not in the sense of
a Taylor expansion,
because a Taylor expansion
wouldn't actually
satisfy a number of
symmetry properties
that we know that the
exact exchange correlation
functional would do.
And so in this sense, all
these new approximation
are called generalized
gradient approximation.
And there is a little menagerie
of acronyms and symbols
that really are sort of
build up upon the names
of the few people that have
really done a lot of work
in this field.
And so you'll see a lot
John Perdew in this,
represented by a P, or
Axel Becke in Canada
by a B, or Kieron Burke
in Rutgers by another B.
So these are some of the
most popular functionals.
I would say that, by now,
sort of almost every one
is standardized on PBE as
being the most reasonable
and the most accurate
advanced approximation
beyond local density.
And so this is what we'll use.
There are classes of
more complex functionals.
The quantum chemistry
has done-- community
has done a lot of
work in looking
at hybrid functionals,
functional in which
a certain percentage of the
exchange correlation functional
comes from the density
function approximation.
It could be LDA,
or in most cases,
could be something like PB.
And some amount of Hartree-Fock
exchange is mixed in.
So they really
take Kohn and Sham
equation, in which they
exchange correlation term
as both a component that is
density functional theory-like
and a component that
is Hartree-Fock-like.
And some of them are,
like these two mention
here, can work very well,
especially for molecules.
Somehow, again, Hartree-Fock
comes from atoms and molecules,
and it tends to work
better in that limit.
Density functional
theory is built
on an approximation
like the LDA that
ultimately comes from the
homogeneous electron gas.
So it tends to work better
for solids, and as usual,
the most difficult
cases in which you
have a combination of the two.
If you want to study a
molecule on a solid surface,
then none of these
two approaches
work really exceedingly well.
There is a lot of
work in developing
more complex
functionals that tend
to work better than any of these
that I have mentioned here.
They tend to be
exceedingly complex.
And so again, there
are sort of meta-GGA
functional-- there is a lot
of more complex functional
that starts to depend
not only on the density
and on the gradients, but
then maybe on the Laplacian.
They might depend on
the orbital themselves.
So you find terms like exact
exchange functional and so on.
There is a lot of
current work, and there
isn't a unique solution.
And also they tend to be so much
more computationally expensive
that, at this stage, I
would say they are still
limited to a development
effort more than an application
effort.
But you see, once we
have a functional--
and this is even done sort
of with standard LDA or TGA,
we can actually describe
with remarkable accuracy
a number of property for
very different materials.
This is a table that
Chris Pickard in Cambridge
had given me, and you see we
have a combination of metals,
semiconductors, oxides, alloys.
And what we have
here, say, is a list
of what is the experimental
lattice parameter,
and what is the
theoretical prediction.
And you see we are sort
of in the range in which
the errors are around 1%.
And I would say,
for most materials,
we are really in this ballpark.
The error on a lattice
parameter of a material that
doesn't have exotic
electronic properties is not
a high-Tc superconductor,
is not as strongly
correlated electronic
material can
be expected to be in the
range of an error that
is between 1% and 2%.
So very, very good.
You see predictive power.
When we calculate with density
functional theory the lattice
parameter of this, we
are really not trying
to fit any potential at all.
When we calculate the
lattice parameter of silver,
we are just saying
there is going
to be an array of Coulombic
potentials attracting
the electrons with the
atomic number of silver.
And we are looking at how the
total energy of this system
varies with lattice parameters.
And that's why, if you want,
electronic structure approaches
tend to be extremely powerful,
because they are not fitted.
We are just trying to find the
electronic structure solution.
So how does it work in practice?
And what I'm going
to describe here
is what's become known by
now as the total-energy
pseudopotential approach.
This is really the approach
that has been developed
to study solid systems.
Again, you have to keep in
mind these two communities--
one of sort of solid-state
extended studies of matter,
and one of atoms and molecules.
And really density
functional theory
comes from these solid
state approaches.
And for reasons that
we'll see in a moment that
are really related
to what we use
as a basis set to
describe electrons
in a solid, what become
apparent very early on
is that describing accurately
the core electron in an atom
or in a solid would have
been exceedingly complex.
If you think at it, whenever
you have an atom that
forms a molecule or
a solid, you have
a lot of electrons
that are going
to be basically unaffected
by the chemical environment.
If you take an iron atom, and
you put it in iron as a metal,
you put as iron in a
transition metal oxide,
or you put as iron as a center,
say, in a heme grouping--
hemoglobin or myoglobin--
what happens is that the
valence electrons or iron
will redistribute themselves.
But really, the core
electron of irons
are so tightly bound to the
nucleus by order of magnitude
in energy with
respect to the sort
of typical energy
of valence electrons
that they are
basically unaffected.
And so in some ways,
we really don't
want to carry all the
computational expense
of describing core
electrons when
we know that their
contribution is
going to be a rigid contribution
that doesn't change depending
on the chemical environment.
The core electrons are
certainly important.
They are there.
They are bound to
the nucleus, and they
screen the nucleus charge.
In iron, the 1s electrons--
the two 1s electrons
will be so tightly
bound to the nucleus
that the nucleus
doesn't look to the 2s,
or 2p, or 3s, 3p electrons
as saving 26 protons.
But it really looks
like having 24 protons,
because those two 1s
electrons screen completely.
And so the 2s and 2p really
will also spin almost completely
the nucleus from the point
of view of the 3s and the 3p.
So we want to find out a way
of somehow taking into account
the presence of
that core electrons,
but we don't want to carry
that on in our calculation,
because it's very expensive.
Not to mention that the spatial
variation of core electrons
is going to be extremely sharp.
I'll show you an
example in a moment.
And so we need a lot of
computational information
to describe all the sharp
wiggles that core electrons
will do around the nucleus.
And this problem has been
solved that again from the late
'70s to the early '80s by what
are called pseudopotential
approaches-- in particular,
something that is called--
and you'll see this term often--
norm conserving pseudopotentials
that, in many ways,
are some of the most
complex part of all
these electron
structure approaches.
And I'll just give you a
sort generic flavor of how
they approach this problem.
Once we have sort of
removed the core electrons
from our problems, we
still need to find out
what are the Kohn and Sham
orbitals that minimize
our density functional problem.
And as always-- and again, we'll
see this in the next slide--
we need to find an appropriate
computational representation
of these orbitals.
And that is in particular
will expand those orbitals
on a basis.
That is, we'll represent any
possible orbital in a problem
as a linear combination
of simple function.
This is what is
called a basis set.
So in our one dimensional
analysis problem,
when you have got an arbitrary
function, you can expand--
you can do, say,
Fourier analysis.
You can expand it in a
series of sines and cosines.
So the same general
problem applies here.
We have arbitrary functions
in three dimensions that
are our orbitals, and we want
to find an appropriate basis
set that describe them.
So this basis set
needs to be accurate--
that this, needs to
be flexible enough
to describe all the possible
wiggles of our orbitals,
but also need to be
computationally convenient.
And we'll go in
that in a moment.
So once we have sort of put
together these elements,
we have sort of our external
potential being represented
by this set of
nuclei, and somehow,
via the pseudopotential
approach,
also the core electrons.
And once we have decided
what is our basic set,
we really need to go and
solve self-consistently
either the Kohn
and Sham equation
that you have seen
before, or we want
to minimize the nonlinear
energy functional.
And so there are sort
of several steps.
Usually, what we'll do is we'll
start from a trial solution.
Remember that, since
the Hamiltonian depends
on the charge density,
we need to have
a guess to our
initial charge density
to even construct our operator,
because our operator depends
on the ground state
charge density.
So since that we don't have
the ground state charge
density when we
start our problem,
we need to start with
a trial solution.
It could be a trial
charge density.
Could be trial orbitals.
But once we have that, all
our operator is well defined.
So we can calculate all
the different terms--
the quantum kinetic
energy, the Hartree energy,
the exchange correlation terms.
And we can try to
solve that Hamiltonian
from that Hamiltonian.
We'll find new orbitals,
and with those new orbitals,
we'll calculate the ground
state charge density,
and we'll obtain a
new Hamiltonian that
then will sort of
keep iterating,
finding new orbitals, new
charge density, new Hamiltonian,
until it reaches a
fixed point, until we
reach self-consistency.
Or we can just take the approach
of minimizing the total energy
functional to self-consistency.
I've written in a more
compact way the problem here.
Well, it'll come in a moment.
So let's describe first
our first computational
approximation in this problem--
that is, the introduction
of pseudopotentials.
And as I said,
what we want to do
is we want to get rid of the
electrons in the inner shells,
in the core of the atoms,
because they really
don't have any contribution
to the valence chemical bonds.
They are just there.
They're important
because they screen
the nucleus in a very specific
quantum mechanical term,
but they really don't
change much when
the valence
coordination changes.
We call that, actually, a
frozen core approximation.
That is, we take an atom--
again, we take an iron atom.
We solve the density functional
problem for the iron atom.
That is, we find a density
functional orbital for the 1s,
2s, 2p, 3s, 3p,
and so on orbitals.
For an atom, it's reasonable to
do that [INAUDIBLE] solution,
even for the core
electrons, because you
have spherical symmetry.
And the problem is still
sort of fairly simple.
And at this point, we say,
well, from now on, we are not
going to describe
the full iron atom,
but we are going always
to deal with a pseudo iron
atom in which the nucleus and
the 1s, 2s, and 2p electrons
have been frozen.
And so what really the
valence electron need to see
is a pseudo nucleus
that is not given
just by the bare
Coulombic potential,
but by the bare Coulombic
potential screened
by this 1s, and 2s,
and 2p electron frozen
in their atomic configuration.
And there is a theorem that
we won't dwell into by-- from
Barth and Gelatt from the '80s--
that says that this freezing
of the core electrons
is actually a very
good approximation.
It doesn't really matter.
It's been verified
over and over again.
It Is the last thing
we have to worry about.
To be precise, the
only thing that we
have to worry about in
density functional theory,
apart from making sure that
our technical approximations--
computation approximation
are all accurate
is the exchange
correlation functional.
That is truly the
only source of error.
And so here, if you
want, I've represented
the idea of a pseudo potential.
This would have been the
standard solution for an atom.
Actually, here I've chosen
something simpler than iron.
I've chosen aluminum.
And so we would have had a
Kohn and Sham set of equations
for aluminum in which,
again, this term
here contains the Hartree
potential, the exchange
correlation potential,
and external potential
that would be just the
bare nuclear potential.
We solve this problem.
What we find?
Well, we find this
hierarchy of states.
You see, we find two
electrons in the 1s state.
We find two electrons in the
2s, two electrons in the 2p.
But really, the electrons
that do all the chemistry
are the 3s and 3p electrons.
And you see the enormous
difference in energy scales.
So the binding energy of the
1s electrons to the nucleus
is 1,500 electron volts.
There is no way,
unless you are sort
of throwing X-rays of very
high energy to those electrons,
that you are going to affect or
perturb in any significant way
these 1s electrons.
Remember, the energy
of a hydrogen bond
is 0.29 electrons-- is a
fraction of an electronvolt.
So this is four orders
of magnitude larger.
So what we want is we want
to say this set of electrons
are so tightly
bound that we don't
need to consider how they
change during the formation
of a chemical bond.
And so what we want to
find is a new potential
that we call our
pseudopotential, such
that the eigenstates
in the presence
of this pseudopotential give us
solutions that really reproduce
exactly the valence electron
solution of the original atom.
So you see, what we want is
we want to go from 13 over r,
the Coulombic potential
that is contained in here
for the bare aluminum nucleus,
to a new potential that somehow
contains both the bare
potential of the nucleus,
the screening from
the core electrons,
and it is constructed according
to a well-defined prescription
so that the eigenstates of
this new set of Kohn and Sham
equation are in order.
The lowest eigenstates
are actually
the valence eigenstates
of our regional problem.
We get the same eigenvalues,
and we get, in a way
that I'll specify in a moment,
the same eigenfunctions.
And so here, it's how we would
actually look at this problem.
And this is a figure courtesy
of Chris [INAUDIBLE]..
So you see, what we
usually ever in an atom
is a Coulombic potential,
is this thin red line here.
This is the potential
as a function
of the radial distance.
So it diverges.
It goes to minus
infinity Coulombically.
For aluminum, it
would go as 13 over r.
What are the solutions, say,
for the 1s state in this--
sorry, what would be the
solution for a valence electron
in this potential?
Well, there are going to be
all the sort of core electrons,
but then a valence electron
would look something like this.
It has-- you see this enormous
number of oscillations.
The reason why those
oscillations are there
is that eigenfunction of
the Kohn and Sham equation
need to be orthogonal
to each other.
This is another
one of these sort
of fundamental quantum
mechanical rules.
It's basically the
Pauli principles.
You can't have two electrons
in the same quantum states.
And in particular,
electrons corresponding
to different quantum states need
to be orthogonal to each other.
So the integral of the psi
star of theta 3s electron
in aluminum times the psi of
the 1s electron in aluminum
needs to be 0.
And so what it means is that the
higher you go, the more wiggles
you have.
And these wiggles-- that
is, these changes of signs
is what allows
you orthogonality.
So if you have a 1s electron
that looks like this,
a 1s electron will
have actually sort
of exponential to the minus
r decaying wave function.
The wave function say-- already
the 2s wave function needs
to be orthogonal
to this electron,
and so it needs to change
sign to allow orthogonality
when you take the product
of these two orbitals.
So orthogonality creates
a lot of wiggles,
and these wiggles also
make the charge density
coming from a valence
electron more spread
towards the outside
of the nucleus.
There is, if you want,
another quantum mechanical
derived effect in which
valence electrons are
moved outwards because of
this orthogonality constraint.
And so you see this would be,
in light blue, the exact wave
function for a valence electron.
And what we want to find
is a pseudopotential that
substitutes for the original
bare Coulombic potential--
and it's written here in sort
of-- with a thick red line--
that is constructed so that its
ground state wave function--
that is here in a thick blue--
has the same energy eigenvalue
of the valence electron.
And in many ways, it's identical
to the original wave function.
And the way we make it
identical is actually
we only require
it to be identical
to our original solution
outside the core,
because outside of
the core of the atom
is where chemistry takes place.
Chemistry will be here when
atoms bind with other atoms.
Inside here, this is the region
where core electron sits,
and that's a region that will
never overlap with other atoms,
again, because there are
sort of already these very
strongly bound electrons.
And to bring two atoms to
have their core regions to
overlap requires
enormous pressure,
hundreds of gigapascals.
So we never really
have to worry.
So what we are
trying to do here is
we want to construct a
pseudopotential in thick red
such that its ground state
wave functions in thick blue
have the same eigenvalues of
my original eigenfunctions
in thin blue lines.
And in many ways, they
represent the same physics
and the same
chemistry, because they
are sort of identical
outside the core.
So the thick red line is
how we describe an atom.
The bare Coulombic potential--
but we also built all
the screening action
from the core
electrons, and you see
the central feature
of the pseudopotential
is that, if you want, it becomes
repulsive around the center
of the atom because
we really need
to keep the valence electron
to be mostly delocalized
in the valence region.
How to build this
pseudopotential
is actually a complex
and somehow dark art.
By now, it's been perfected,
and that-- there are basically
tables of pseudopotential.
So it's a problem you almost
never have to worry anymore.
An electronic
structure code will
have a set of pseudopotential.
And in the course
of the years, there
have been two flavors
that have been developed.
The first one that was
actually, I would say,
invented at Bell Labs at the
end of the '70s by Hamann,
Schluter, and Chiang
is what are called
norm conserving
pseudopotential, of which I'll
describe this plot in a moment.
There was a sort of improvement
of this norm conserving
pseudopotential that are called
ultrasoft pseudopotential,
developed by David Vanderbilt
at Rutgers University.
They tend to be much
less expensive to be--
to use in practical
calculation, basically
because they are
smoother and smoother,
and so they can be described
with sort of a smaller
basis set, and they
tend to be more
accurate over a broader range
of coordination and energies.
But so the general idea
of the pseudopotential
from a different way--
in the previous slide, I
showed you how it looks like.
But the genetic idea
of a pseudopotential
is that we want to
create something
that contains both the nucleus
and these core electrons.
And that basically will
act on the valence electron
in the same way as the true
problem of core electron
explicitly and nucleus.
And so what we say is
that we want a pseudo
potential to scatter
an incoming wave,
an incoming electron
in the same way
as our real set of core
electrons in an atom
would do that.
And in order to do
that very accurately,
for this pseudopotential,
what we need to do
is actually to have
the pseudopotential
not just be a single local
form, as in the previous slide.
It's shown you the sort of
red thick line that was just
a unique form of the
potential as a function of r,
but we actually want
our pseudopotential
to be different, depending on
the angular momentum component
of the electron coming.
So if you have a
valence electron,
and you have a
valence wave function,
you can actually say that that
valence wave function will
have a 20% angular symmetry of
the S type, 30% of the P type,
30% of the D type, and
so on and so forth.
And what you do is
you act differently
on the S component
of the wave function,
on the P component of the wave
function, on the D component,
and so on and so forth.
And so this would be the
different radial parts
of the pseudopotential,
depending on which
components they act on.
They all have this
overall 1 over r--
or z over r asymptotic trend.
But as we get more close to the
nucleus, they start deferring.
You see, from the
core region inwards,
they are all different.
And in particular, they are
all, or at least in part,
repulsive to again represent
this frozen set of electrons.
And this is how the
corresponding wave functions
would look like.
And I've made-- again,
this is for an indium atom,
a comparison between, say, the
p all electron wave function
and the pseudo wave function.
And you see they are identical
in the valence region,
but in the core region, the
true all electron valence wave
function is a lot
of oscillation,
while the pseudo wave
function is much smoother.
And this smoothness
means that we
can describe this pseudo wave
function in sines and cosines
with a much smaller set of waves
at different wavelengths then
we would have to
do if we were to--
if we had the need to describe
all this high frequency
oscillation.
So at the end,
pseudopotential are just there
to sort of give us a
chance to avoid describing
all these high frequency
oscillation of the true valence
wave function, and
also to give us
the possibility of avoiding
the explicit description
of the core
electrons that really
don't change their shape
in going from the atom
to the solid.
So now with this, we have
an exchange correlation
functional.
We have this new approximation
to the external potential
given by a sort of
array of pseudopotential
centered on each nucleus.
And so we are back to this
sort of self-consistent problem
of having to solve these
Kohn and Sham differential
equations.
And again, the way we want
to attack this problem
on a computer is by making this
problem into a numerical matrix
algebra problem.
And the way we go about this
is by choosing a busy set
and expanding our
orbitals in a basis.
That is, we say by saying that
any sort of generating function
can be thought of as
a linear combination
of a set of simple function.
Simple function, for which we
can do analytical operation--
that is, we are able, say, to
calculate the matrix elements,
say, of the kinetic energy
between this simple function,
or we are able to
calculate analytically
the second derivative
of this basis function.
Well, by making this ansatz,
by saying that a generic wave
function is a linear
combination of this,
our problem transforms from a
differential analysis problem
to a problem of finding
these coefficients.
And again, sort of the
basis set that we'll
choose in all sort of our
practical computational lab
will really be a basis
set of sines and cosines,
or what we call plane waves.
That is especially
adapted and especially
useful for the case of solids.
And I've given you
an example here.
Suppose that what
we want to describe
is a Gaussian charge
density, something
that is a little bit similar to
the charge density in an atom.
Well, this localized
charge density
can be actually expressed
fairly accurately
as a linear combination of
very few sines or cosines
with different wavelengths.
You see, I go from
this wavelength
to smaller and
smaller wavelength.
And if I choose my
coefficients such
that I have constructive
interference here
in the center and destructive
interference outside,
I actually get just by
something nine terms here,
something that basically
describes perfectly
my charge density.
So this will be our general
sort of approach to the problem.
We choose a basis set.
That is, we choose a set
of elementary functions
that are particularly suited
to describe our problem,
and for which we can do all
the analysis that we want.
That is, we are able to
calculate second derivatives.
We are able to calculate
matrix elements analytically.
And then our
computational problem
becomes really just a problem
of finding the coefficients.
And this is one of those
approximations for which you
need to test the accuracy.
That is, if you use a
very small business set,
if you use only 10 plain waves
with different wavelengths,
your calculation will
be very inexpensive,
because you have only 10
coefficients to work with.
But it probably won't
be very accurate.
If you use one
million plane waves,
your calculation will
be extremely accurate,
but it will be also
very expensive.
So this is an approximation,
but an approximation-- and this
is fundamental-- for which
you can control the accuracy.
That is, you just need to
make sure that your business
set is good enough.
And that is something that
you can always check and test.
You can't test, apart from
comparison with experiment,
if your exchange correlation
functional is good enough.
That's why we put
so much importance,
and you should never forget that
really all the accuracy or all
the errors that ultimately
come in your calculation
come from the exchange
correlational function.
All the other computational
numerical approximation
using pseudopotentials,
using a finite basis set
are all approximations
that can be tested.
And we always assume that a
well done electronic structure
calculation will have
those under control.
You are using enough basis sets.
You are using accurate
pseudopotential, and so on.
As I said, in solids,
for a reason that you'll
see in a moment, really the
universal basis of choice
is that of plane
waves-- basically
the e to the I
complex exponential,
and you'll see why.
But in a sort of--
atoms and molecules-- their
almost universal basis
choice is that a
combination of Gaussians.
And the reason why
Gaussians have been chosen,
and actually why the most
famous quantum chemistry
code is called Gaussian
is that it's very easy
to do the analytical
integrals that
are present in the exchange
term for Hartree-Fock.
So if you want an exchange
term for Hartree-Fock,
the term means the
choice of Gaussian
as a particularly
convenient basis set.
And again, the product of
two Gaussians is a Gaussian,
and that's why this is
ultimately a good choice.
This is what has developed.
At the end, you can still use
Gaussians to study solids,
or you can use plane
waves to study molecules.
And there is even a sort
of richer phenomenology.
But generally speaking,
these two approaches,
that of localized
functions in chemistry
and of delocalized function
in extended systems,
are the basic categories.
We'll start from the
point of view of solids,
and then you'll
see why we actually
describe-- we use plain waves
to describe these orbitals.
And when you deal
with solid, you
need to be aware of one of
the fundamental symmetries
that the eigenstates
of our solution
in our periodic potential,
as what happens in solids,
satisfy.
That is, in particular,
the Hamiltonian of a solid
is periodically invariant.
That's the characteristic
of a solid.
It's a regular periodic array of
externals pseudopotential that
[INAUDIBLE].
So in the language
of quantum mechanics,
we say that the
Hamiltonian commutes
with the translational operator.
Translation operator
by a vector--
that is, a direct
lattice vector.
So if you take out cubic system
and you displace, you translate
your set of potentials by
1 cubic lattice vector,
you have the same operator.
That is, trivially
to say that, if you
have a regular array of blue
dots that is infinite in space,
and you displace them, and
the displaced one r crosses,
and they have been displaced
by this lattice vector r here,
and both the red dots
and the blue dots
are infinite,
well, by displacing
the blue dot into
the red dots, you
have the same identical problem.
When two operator commuting
quantum mechanics, what we know
is that we can find eigenstates
that are common eigenstates.
That is, they are eigenstates
both of the first operator,
and then on the second operator.
I won't dwell on
this in case you
are not familiar with parts
of this quantum mechanical
problem.
But what I want to highlight
is that the net result,
the fact that we can
choose eigenvectors that
are common eigenvectors
of the Hamiltonians
and of the translation
operator, tells us
that a genetic eigenvector
for aperiodic potential
needs to have a very well
defined symmetry and a very
well defined symmetric form.
And that's sort of summarized
in the Bloch theorem.
And that tells us
that an eigenvector
will be given by a term--
a function that has the same
periodicity of the crystal
times a plane wave--
again, a complex
exponential that
modulates these
periodic parts and that
can have any wavelength.
So in other words, what the
Bloch theorem here is telling
us is that the solutions,
the eigenstates
of aperiodic Hamiltonian can
have any possible periodicity.
You don't have to think at
the electronic eigenstates
of aperiodic Hamiltonian as
having the same periodicity
of your lattice.
But the shape that they
have is actually this.
That is the product
of two function--
one that has any arbitrary
wavelength, and another term--
the so-called periodic part
of our orbitals-- that does
have the same periodicity
of the lattice.
This can be proven
in a variety of ways,
and somehow I summarized
here why ultimately this
is the shape that
the eigenfunction
of the Hamiltonian
needs to have,
basically because if
we have a translation
and the Hamiltonian
is invariant,
the charge density of your
solid must also be invariant.
And this solution
satisfies that,
because if you look at the
wave function-- not at r,
but r plus a direct
lattice vector--
this term will be
unchanged by definition
because this term
has the periodicity.
This term will become
e to the ik times
scalar product r plus a
direct lattice vector.
But when you look at the
charge density-- that is,
the square modulus--
this term disappears.
So only this remains
in the charge density.
And you also want
two translations
being equivalent to the
sum of the other two.
And again, if you translate
that by two consecutive lattice
vectors, this term
doesn't change.
And the exponential of a
sum of two lattice vectors
is going to be just the
product of two exponentials
for each lattice vector.
But the fundamental
concept here is
this-- that the
wave function are
modulated by this wavelength
and we actually classify them.
We do these two quantum numbers.
As we classify orbitals
in the periodic table,
we give them quantum numbers.
We say this is going to be
a 3s electron with spin-up.
We are saying what
the quantum number nlm
and spin are for that electron.
In a solid, these are
our quantum numbers.
We have a bond index.
That is, if you wanted solid
equivalent of your energy
levels, and it's actually
a discrete integer index
that somehow classifies
the different eigenvectors,
but those eigenvectors can
have also any wavelength.
And so the wavelength
of the block orbital
is another quantum number
that characterize our system.
So when you actually
look at a molecule,
you think that in
terms of energy levels,
and you draw an energy
diagram in which you will
have a 1s, 2s, 3s energy level.
When you think of the
possible energy levels
from four electrons
in a solid, you'll
draw a more complex band
diagram in which you
will sort of classify
levels, not only in terms
of discrete integers, but also
in terms of the wavelength.
And so this is what is usually
band energy diagram, of which I
have an example here.
So this is-- would be the
solid equivalent of the energy
levels.
So for a molecule,
you would have
a discrete set of energy level.
For a solid, you don't have
only a set of discrete quantum
numbers n, but you have also a
continuous set of wavelengths.
So you have bands
that show you how
your energy of that
eigenvector changes
depending on the wavelength
of that eigenvector.
And what I've plotted
here is actually
the band energy diagram for
a free electron in an FCC
lattice.
What I'm saying is
that, suppose that I'm
considering an electron that
doesn't feel any potential.
What would be its band energy?
Well, it's band
energy is actually
going to be a parabola.
So it's something that
we would represent
as this sort of
energy, as being really
proportional to its wavelength.
That is, again, because a
free electron is represented
by a plain wave e to the ikr.
And so the second
derivative of a plain wave--
that is, the quantum
kinetic energy--
is just the k squared term.
And if an electron is free,
there is no potential.
So we can think of the energy
as a function of wavelength
for a free electron to
be perfectly parabolic.
But now what we can
think for a moment
is also how to
represent this parabola.
In principle, this parabola
is a single parabola infinite
as a function of wavelength.
But we can also, for a moment,
represent the data in an FCC
or in any arbitrary
periodic lattice.
So what we could be saying is
that suppose that now there
is an imaginary geometric
structure that is,
say, in real space Bravais
lattice with FCC periodicity,
and that, in reciprocal
space, will correspond
to a BCC reciprocal lattice.
And what I want to do is I
want to take this parabola
and fold it.
So instead of having a
single parabolic branch that
extends to infinity, every
time I hit in Brillouin zone
in the reciprocal
space a boundary,
I fold this parabola back.
So what I've shown here is
really the band energy diagram
that is a parabola,
supposing for a moment
that my electron leaves in the
geometry of an FCC lattice.
And this is just to
give you the feeling
that sometimes something
that looks very complex
is just a representation
of something very simple
in a specific geometry.
And now you see in a
moment what happens
if we study the electron in a
system that truly has the FCC
Bravais lattice in real space.
And so it is a BCC Bravais
lattice in reciprocal space.
And that is silicon.
And you see that the
band energy dispersions
for electrons in silicon
looked, actually very, very
similar to free electrons.
You see now for a
moment something
that you thought it
was always extremely
complex, like the band
diagram for silicon,
turns out to be just a
parabola, just a free electron
slightly modified.
And you can clearly see
all the same pieces,
but obviously now
these electrons,
these valence
electrons in silicon
feel the periodic potential.
And so the overall
solution is modified.
And for those of you
familiar with solids,
there is a band gap
between valence electrons
and conduction electrons.
And here, we would
be at a gamma point.
This would be the
lowest valence band,
and here we would have the
heavy and the light whole bands
for the top valence--
for the top valence bands.
But what this is telling us
is that electrons in a solid
really look like free
electrons with a little bit
of a perturbation that is enough
to transform this parabola
into something different.
And again, because they
are almost free electrons,
and because they have
the periodicity--
the periodic part of
the Bloch orbitals
need to have the periodicity
of the crystal lattice
that we are studying--
it will actually
be extremely appropriate
to use as a basis set
to describe at each k
point in the Brillouin.
The periodic part of
the Bloch orbitals
will be extremely convenient
to use plane waves.
And this is the
reason, ultimately,
why I written here,
sort of again reminding
some basics of crystallography.
I've taken, say, the
zinc blende structure.
So again, an FCC lattice here,
where these three here in green
would be the primitive lattice
vectors of the FCC lattice--
so what I am calling
here a1, a2 and a3.
And these three lattices--
three vector lattices in 1/2,
1/2, 0, 0, 1/2, 1/2, and 1/2,
0, 1/2 really represents
my Bravais lattice
by repeating blue atoms at any
linear combination of three--
of these three vectors.
I span all the infinite
blue sublattice
of the cations in a zinc blende.
And the zinc blende is just a
parallel compound of silicon.
It's just that the second atom
in the unit cell is different.
And again, by
applying translations
that are linear combination
of these green vectors,
I span all the blue lattice.
And silicon would be
identical to this.
Just the red and the
blue would be identical.
So having defined
direct vector lattices,
the a1, a2, and a3, what I can
define is a set of dual vectors
that we call reciprocal lattice
vectors g1, g2, and g3 that
are such that the scalar
product between g1 and g2
is either 1 or 0.
And this is the [INAUDIBLE]
delta times 2 pi.
This is a definition.
This is what we know
is the definition
of the reciprocal
lattice vector,
but what is very
important for us
is that these primitive
reciprocal lattice vectors are
the fundamental descriptor of
all the plane waves that I want
to use in describing a solid
and the reason for that
is that a plane wave written
like this exponential of iGr,
where the G here, where
this vector is just
a linear combination
with integer
number of my primitive
lattice vectors--
so it's going to be l
with l integer G1 times G2
to times n G3.
So well defined by the
triplet of numbers l, m, n.
Well, these plane
waves, e to the iGr,
for any linear combination
of g1, g2, and g3
is a function,
defined in real space,
that is a periodicity
compatible with the periodicity
of my direct lattice.
So suppose that we were in
one dimension for a moment,
and I would have a system
that has this periodicity.
And remember, the periodic
part of the Bloch orbitals
will have the same
periodicity in real space.
So maybe the
periodic part of that
will look something like this,
with the same periodicity.
Well, then what I want
to do is really expand
this periodic function
as a linear combination
with appropriate
coefficient of plane waves
with different
wavelengths, but I
need to choose these
plane waves to all
have the same periodicity
of the green lattice.
So my plane waves will
only look like this,
and this will be the sort
of fundamental harmonic
if you want.
And then another plane wave
could have this periodicity,
and so on and so forth, going
to higher and higher wavelength.
But the compact mathematical
representation of this
is in here.
That is, given a
direct lattice defined
by the three vectors
a1, a2, and a3,
I can define a
reciprocal lattice
that is represented by the
three vector G1, G1, and G3.
And any linear combination with
integer numbers of this G1, G2,
and G3 will give me a vector
G such that the complex
exponential e to
the iGr is actually
a periodicity that is compatible
with my direct lattice.
That is, the moment I
create a direct lattice,
there are an infinite
number of wavelengths
that are not compatible
with the periodicity
that I've thrown into my system.
Those disappear.
I don't want to have
anything to deal with.
What I'm left is with
a numerable infinity
of plane waves that are all
compatible with the direct
lattice that I'm choosing from.
And you see now there
is a natural way
of both choosing plane waves--
they will be here--
and also a natural way to
choose the most important one,
because when we choose our
basis set for our calculation,
we'll start from the plane
waves of longer wavelength.
That is, that the
blue wavelength
that I've plotted here--
and will decrease
the wavelength.
That will include more
and more plane wave
that sort of have finer
and finer wavelength, finer
and finer resolution.
And that can be
just naturally done
by including plane waves
with G vectors that
have a larger square modulus.
That is the larger this G vector
here, the finer the resolution,
the higher the wavelength
of this plane wave.
So there is truly a
natural way to choose
basis set now,
because, again, what
we have is a reciprocal space.
And so we'll have a
Brillouin zone in red.
We'll have, if I'm
in two dimension,
the two G1 and G2 vectors.
And so the linear combination
G's that I've described
will be given by the infinite,
but discrete set of G vectors
represented here.
And so only the G vectors
denoted here with a cross
give rise to a
plane wave that has
the compatible periodicity
with my periodic boundary
conditions.
And so in order to choose
a basis set, what I do,
I just draw a circle, or in
three dimensions, a sphere,
and I decide to include
all the vector that
sit inside that sphere.
And by making that
sphere larger and larger,
I'm going to include
G vectors that
have larger and larger modules
that is finer and finer
wavelength.
And that is what is called
your cutoff in your basis set.
So one of the fundamental
parameters of your calculation
will be choosing your cutoff
for your plane wave basis set--
that is, choosing the radius of
that sphere that includes plane
waves with wavelength compatible
to the periodic boundary
conditions up to a
certain resolution.
You make this cutoff
sphere larger and larger.
You systematically include
finer and finer resolutions,
so you become better and better
at describing your problem.
And you'll always need to
check in your first calculation
that your basis
set is good enough.
That is, by increasing
your cutoff radius,
you will not see any
significant physical change
in the quantities that
you are calculating.
You don't see a physical
change in the energy
as a function of volume.
You don't see a change in the
forces acting on atoms, and so
on and so forth.
This will take forever.
Again, this is not the
only choice of basis set,
but as you can see, it's
really the appropriate one
for periodic systems.
And it has sort of a set of nice
advantages, of which I would
say the most important
is the fact that it's
systematic in the sense that
you can continuously improve
the resolution in your problem
by including more plane waves.
There is a negative
side to this that
says that it doesn't have
any information on how
valence electrons should
look like close to a nucleus
or close to a core.
It requires a very large
number of basis elements.
So plane wave
calculation tend to have
a lot of elements in that.
There are a number of
other important practical
consequences.
In particular, as
much as Gaussians,
they allow for very
easy evaluation
of some of the analytical
terms that we need.
So it's very easy to take
the gradient of a plane wave
or the Laplacian
of a plane wave,
because basically the derivative
of a complex exponential,
if you have e the iGr, the
derivative with respect
to r of this is just
the function itself
times the vector G. This
would be the gradient,
and the Laplacian-- that is,
the second derivative-- is just
G squared times
the wave function.
And so all these terms
are easy to calculate,
and there is a sort of more
subtle conclusion of this,
that if you start to have a
calculation in which atoms
move, like a molecular dynamic
calculation in which you need
to calculate things
like forces, you
need to calculate the derivative
of the energy with respect
to the position of an atom.
But now the energy in
itself is an expression
that involves linear
combination of your basis set.
Well, this basis
set does not depend
on the position of the atom.
So there is no term in the
force in the derivative
of the energy with
respect to the position
that comes from this.
If, on the other hand, you are
using, say, a Gaussian that
was centered on an atom, a
Gaussian centered on an atom
would have in there the
position of the atom.
And so in order to take
the derivative, the force,
you would also need to take a
derivative of your basis set.
And these are what are
called Pulay terms.
And that just add another
layer of complexity
to your calculation.
And again, this is,
I think, ultimately,
is one of the reasons why
in the solid-state community
problems like molecular
dynamics and forced relaxation
were developed earlier,
basically because it's much
simpler to calculate forces.
And I want to give
you an example on how
certain parts of
your problem become
very easy in your solution.
In particular, remember
sort of in the construction
of the self-consistent operator
from the charge density
we needed to construct
the Hartree operator
from the charge density integral
of n over r minus r prime.
Well, that's
basically a solution
of what is called
the Poisson equation.
That is, given a charge
density, the Hartree potential
is really coming from the
solution of this differential
equation.
That is, the Laplacian,
the second derivative
of the Hartree potential
is equal to minus,
in atomic units, 4 pi the
n electronic charge density
taken as positive here
in particular, just
to get the signs right.
This is a differential equation.
We need to solve
it in the course
of our self-consistent
problem, because remember,
we have sort of
diagonalized Hamiltonian.
We have gotten some orbitals.
From those orbitals, we have
calculated a charge density.
But now, from the
charge density,
we need to calculate the
electrostatic potential.
And that's how it works.
Well, this differential
equation is actually
trivial to solve
if, for a moment,
you think at a
plane wave solution.
That is, you think
that your potential--
that is, a function
of r is now being
written as a linear combination
where the coefficients are
called v of g of plane waves.
So I'm taking my potential.
It's going to have
the same periodicity
of the reciprocal
lattice, and I'm
writing it out as a linear
combination of waves.
And I'm doing the same for
the charge density here.
So the charge
density in itself is
going to be given by
a linear combination
with coefficient
G of plane waves.
So this is my expansion in
plane waves of this real space
functions.
And then the algebra is
trivial, because to take
the derivative of this red
term here, what I obtain
is nothing else
than the sum over g.
Second derivative will give me
r minus g squared v Hartree of G
e to the iGr.
And that is-- needs to be
equal to, well, minus 4 pi sum
over G n of G e to the iGr.
So I have done nothing
else than inserting
the explicit expansion
in plane waves
of my potential of
my charge density
in the differential equation.
And now, well, sort
of mathematically I
can actually sort of multiply
the left and the right hand
term for something like e to
the minus iG prime times r.
And then I can
integrate in the r.
And this is just the
mathematical operation
that on an
orthonormal basis set,
as this is, tells me that,
in order for this equality
to be satisfied, what I
really need to have is
that each coefficient
corresponding to the same G
vector on the left hand side
and on the right hand side
is separately equal.
So the solution to the
Poisson-Boltzmann equation
is trivial, because
what I need to have is
that G square vG is
equal to 4 pi nG.
That is, each coefficient
needs to be identical G by G.
So if I have a charge
density in real space,
I can expand it in plane waves.
And this coefficient and
nothing else than a Fourier
transform, so a computer
is very good, given
a periodic function
in real space,
to give me these coefficients.
And once I have this
coefficient n of G,
I will know instantly
what are the coefficients
of the potential that is
the solution of this Poisson
equation, because those
vG coefficients are really
just my charge density
coefficient multiplied by 4 pi
and divided by G square.
So you see with
plane waves, a lot
of the analytical work
in a transaction problem
becomes trivial.
And here, it's contained
one of the trickiest part
of electronic
structure calculation.
And the reason why electronic
structure calculation
of large system becomes more
and more computationally
ill-defined, and more
and more difficult to do
as the size of the
system becomes larger,
because as the size of
the system becomes larger,
your cell in real space
will become larger.
And your Brillouin zone
in reciprocal space
will become smaller and smaller.
As the three a1, a2,
a3 vectors becomes
larger, the three dual
reciprocal space vector--
G1, G1, and G3--
becomes smaller.
So the smallest of the G vector
will become smaller and smaller
as the supercell grows.
And so then you see that
there is an instability,
because this component
of the Hartree potential
is given by this n coefficient
divided by G square.
As your system becomes larger,
G square becomes smaller.
And so as smaller
numerical instability
in your charge density gives
you a large instability
in your potential.
And so you need to be
more and more careful.
You need to become
more and more careful
in your electrostatic solution
as the problem becomes
larger and larger.
This will take forever to say.
I think that I need to
stop here for today,
and what we'll see in the
next class on Thursday
will sort of wrap up the
last few technical details
that you need to go into the
computational lab on Tuesday,
and we'll start discussing
case studies for our density
functional problem.
As a reminder-- and I've
emailed and hope all of you have
received my email--
in order to do the
computational lab on Tuesday,
it is essential that
each and every one of you
has an independent
personal computer
account on the computer class,
because this calculation will
become expensive.
And we need to run them not
on the main a central node.
That will collapse if more than
two or three of you run on it.
But we need to spool
it via queuing system
on the nodes of the cluster that
lie beneath the master nose.
This is all for today.
Enjoy the snow, and see
you on Thursday morning.